hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us for today's webinar TSH
receptor antibodies nomenclature
functionality and a state comparison
presented by dr. George Kuh Haley master
of medicine and endocrinology metabolism
Johannes Gutenberg University Medical
Center Mons Germany I'm Christie jewel
of lever can I'll be your moderator for
today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laboratories a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars
it is sponsored by Cueto to learn more
about our sponsor please visit quite
Elcom
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that the student is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type your questions into the
drop down box and click send our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
following the presentation
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you are
experiencing a problem
presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
our speaker today is dr. George K Haley
- Hailie currently holds the rank a
professor of medicine and endocrinology
metabolism and his chief of the
endocrine outpatient clinic at the
Johannes Gutenberg University Medical
Center Mons Germany
dr. K Halley directs the endocrine
research laboratory and has offered more
than 160 original papers covering both
clinical and external aspects of
endocrine autoimmunity immuno genetics
of thyroid and poly glandular
autoimmunity as well as cardiovascular
involvement of metabolic disorders you
organized and co-chaired numerous
international scientific meetings
dealing with molecular and endocrine
autoimmunity
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. kay hailey I will now
turn the presentation over to him
my name is George K Haley I'm a
physician working at the Johannes
Gutenberg University Medical Center Mons
Germany and I have the pleasure to
introduce you to the topic TSH receptor
antibodies nomenclature functionality
and as a comparison now this is my
disclosure she start with the topic TSH
receptor antibody I have to go a step
back showing you actually the cause of
hyperthyroidism which is in use by the
simulation of the thyroid gland by
thyroid stimulating on two bodies these
antibodies are produced within the
thyroid glands the lead to stimulation
of the thyroid cells leading to release
and increase release of thyroid-related
hormone not t3 and t4 causing
hyperthyroidism now if you have an
increased t3 and t4 this will suppress
the pituitary release of TSH which is a
hormone produced by the pituitary now
the classical phenotype of
hyperthyroidism is an increased his free
level increase t4 levels with a
suppressed or low TSH serum level the
codes of hyperthyroidism is mainly due
to an increased serum level of
stimulating antibodies these antibodies
are called TSH receptor antibodies
because they are binding to the
extracellular domain of the TSH receptor
which is the primary author in tagines
in grave disease and which is a
glycoprotein hormone receptor so these
CSH receptor antibodies are specific for
the disease
burning actually on the surface of the
fire itself the clinical relevance of
TSH receptor antibody has been
emphasized within the 88 guidelines
published recently in the year 2016 and
the first recommendation of these
guidelines is to go for the measurement
of TSH receptor antibodies
telling you that this is warranted for
diagnosis of thyrotoxicosis and although
alternative diagnostic steps are
ultrasound of the thyroid gland or
and/or radioiodine
object but clearly measurement of the
TSH receptor antibody is the clue to
diagnose Graves disease
now these guidelines not only affirm the
use of TSH receptor antibody in their
diagnosis of grave disease these
guidelines go one step further in the
clinical use of the TSH receptor
antibody in monitoring or remission
monitoring for remission or for relapse
as antiviral drug therapy becomes more
widespread in the treatment of grave
disease and or hyperthyroidism the use
of the TSH receptor antibodies become
paramount in disease management
now these TSH receptor antibody are not
only useful today Agnos grave disease
and this is the clinical phenotype of a
patient with Graves disease with diffuse
goiter these antibody are produced
within the thyroid glands leading to
simulation of the fire it sells these
TSH receptor antibody are also relevant
to you actually diagnose patients with
Hashimoto's thyroiditis since we are
differentiating between different
functional auto antibodies they may
stimulate the thyroid but they may also
block the thyroid gland leading to
hypothyroidism and/or destruction of the
thyroid cells and the phenotype is well
known and defined as Hashimoto
thyroiditis now how can we measure these
TSH receptor antibodies we do have to
actually essays the one is the binding
the so called
binding assay it's a commercially
available sa it's a competitive bonding
Amin sa defined a strap or abbreviated
as strap
TSH receptor antibody or tboi Thurid
binding inhibiting immunoglobulins this
sa measure the total ante TSH receptor
binding activity but this sa do not
discriminate the functional type as an
alternative and in contrast the cell
based buyer si is usually dealing with
transfected cell lines using these
transfected cell lines where the TSH
receptor reporter gene and with the help
of this buyer essays we can both measure
the specific stimulating antibodies
abbreviated thyroid stimulating
immunoglobulins or thyroid stimulating
antibodies also and this host through
with the blocking antibody sa we are
measuring the specific TBI or thyroid
blocking immunoglobulin and/or the
thyroid blocking antibodies now this
might be confusing and currently many
actually abbreviation are being used for
example T cell for the TSH receptor
stimulating on tabari or TSI for the TSH
receptor stimulating immunoglobulins or
t bab for TSH receptor blocking
antibodies or TSB antibody thyroid
stimulating blocking antibody or thyroid
receptor blocking antibody also the
abbreviation TR bab forth or
assimilating blocking antibodies and
finally the TBI TSH receptor blocking
immunoglobulins while the abbreviation
TBI are clearly defined the TSH receptor
burning and hibbott or immunoglobulins
it is a competitive burning si so you
have really to clarify the nomenclature
and to differentiate between all these
abbreviation for clarity I will you
always talk about t sub or TSI when
talking about stimulatory antibodies
and I will talk about T Bab what I'm
talking about blocking antibodies I will
use for also to avoid confusion the word
TB III will talk about trab which means
the binding essay the essay not
differentiating between the different
functional antibodies indeed if you have
a sample which is positive for the
binding si for the conventional
commercial si this samples can be 100%
stimulatory antibody positive or 100%
blocking antibody positive called t babe
or you may have a mixture of stimulating
and blocking antibodies or a mixture
between so called blocking and neutral
antibodies or stimulating and blocking
antibodies so to make it clear only the
bio si exclusively differentiate between
the TSH receptor antibody activity not
the Bonnie si the burning si is just
telling you that you are dealing with a
binding of the antibody in the serum to
the TSH receptor to the surface of the
far itself so what is actually the
diagnostic utility of this TSH receptor
stimulating antibody with the bio si it
yields and shares the highest
sensitivity and the highest specificity
according to several randomized raw and
prospective trials showing you also the
superiority of this test in contrast to
the binding antibodies with lower
specificity and lower sensitivity and
also in comparison to third ultrasound
with which is a morphological
investigation of the thyroid gland it is
a sensitive issue but it is not a
specific test also and finally the much
more expensive Raju iodine uptake or
scanning which is really
expensive time-consuming we'll give you
also less specificity and less
sensitivity than the TSH receptor
stimulating antibody bioassay we can use
this buy or sell the results of the TSH
receptor stimulating antibodies if you
want to rapidly diagnose thyrotoxicosis
mainly Auto antibody induce Graves
hyperthyroidism if you have a low TSH as
I have explained before as shown before
in my diagram telling you that if you
are dealing with a suppressed or low TSH
you have to go for the measurement of
stimulating antibodies if these
antibodies are positive they will tell
you the true story that you are dealing
with Graves hypothyroidism while if
these stimulating antibodies are
negative you're dealing with other
causes of thyrotoxicosis for example
toxic nodules or Artemio or should be
acute thyroiditis if your TSH is normal
then you are not dealing with grave
Sarfaraz you're just dealing with you
thyroid subjects healthy subjects or
thyroid healthy persons not having
autoimmune hepatitis rapid flow charge
to diagnose thyrotoxicosis and to
differentiate between Graves
hypothyroidism and other causes of
thyrotoxicosis also from the financial
and economic point of view if you are
using the stimulatory antibody assay
this has an impact on the cost of graves
up authorities and diagnosis you are
reducing the number of thyroid uptake
and scan cost you are reducing the
endocrinologist office visit numbers and
more specifically you are reducing the
total pea cost of Graves disease
diagnosis including the direct cost and
the misdiagnosis cost and you are also
reducing the average time to diagnosis
by nearly 50% so just using the
test will facilitate diagnosis will save
time and money by nearly 50% even more
important than the financial issue is
actually the consequence of the
circulation of this stimulatory antibody
in the body leading to a system of
disease called the systemic autoimmune
grave disease showing extra federal
manifestation the disease thought within
the thyroid but you you may observe a
50% of the cases patients with extra
fara the manifestation produces swelling
of the lids and also retina of the lids
all these patients have so-called
pretibial mix edema with the position
and accumulation of mucopolysaccharides
within the pretibial space within the
legs and you may also have the same
phenomenon with swelling of the fingers
because these chondrocytes and these
fibroids fibroblasts skin cells thyroid
cells and skin target cells are all
expressing the TSH receptor their outer
entities and the circulating antibodies
are causing the systemic disorders we do
observe extra far down manifestation
within the eye and 50% of the cases
observed we do observe pre DPL mix edema
and 5% of the cases and in 1 to 2% we do
see the swelling of the fingers called
acaba he what is this related with the
tighter over the concentration of the
TSH receptor antibody no doubt about it
and this has been shown several times if
you are using if you are looking at
patients with severe or disease cold
graves of the orbital puffy their serum
levels of thyroid stimulating antibody
is significantly higher than those with
thyroid all disease only abbreviated
grave disease so patients with Graves
disease
and graves our disease show the highest
levels so these antibodies may be
recorded regarded as a biomarker of the
thyroid disease of Graves thyroid all
and orbital disease and this is not the
case if you are now looking at so-called
conventional si the trap si they cannot
differentiate between patients with
orbital disease and patients with
thyroid all disease no significant
differences are observed showing you the
sensitivity of the buyer si regarding
the differential diagnosis of patient
with systemic grave disease and this is
also observed in patients not only in
adults but also in children this is a
chart eight years old this is a she this
is how she looked like at the age of six
and when she came to our institution
with Graves hyperthyroidism or produces
eggs of Thomas the lady has a very high
titer this young lady at a very hot
titer of TSH receptor stimulated
antibody so even children are showing
these abnormalities and we are using the
bio sa and the measurement of
stimulatory antibody both in adults as
well as in children now there is also a
problem with these antibodies because
they are crossing the placenta in during
pregnancy this is a lady here she had
Graves disease graves up authorities we
have been treating this lady for two
years she became you thyroid she was
doing well and she became pregnant and
unfortunately the OB Jean ecologist did
not control the TSH receptor antibody
during pregnancy and the this lady
developed actually TSH receptor antibody
and these antibody cross the placenta
causing the neonatal
fetal and neonatal Graves hypothyroidism
this is a severe condition a severe
condition which has been which has to be
treated
and these antibodies survive in the
fetus or inner in the child for at least
three months meaning that the child has
Graves hypothyroidism within the first
three or four months of his life these
antibody will disappear subsequently and
the lady on the right panel is now five
years old this young child developed
normally the hair connective cognitive
function is normal but the most
important problem is actually during
pregnancy where the antibody these
stimulating antibody cross the placenta
so during pregnancy we are dealing with
a problem with the risk for fetus with a
history of patients without enough heart
disease all female with a history of
autoimmune thyroid disease should be
checked for TSH receptor antibody if the
healthy is H receptor antibody they can
cross the placenta and these ladies can
produce stimulatory antibody T sub or
and blocking antibody both antibody are
crossing the placenta and causing
problems there is indeed a risk for
fetal infant hyper and hyperthyroidism
which correlate with the level of the
serum levels of the stimulatory and or
blocking antibodies in the mother blood
this is why measurement of these
antibody during pregnancy is warranted
this is a case severe case of neonatal
thyrotoxicosis surprisingly the mother
was severely hypothermic you couldn't
imagine that this hyperthyroid mother
who was on levothyroxine on high doses
of t4 tablets could deliver a child with
severe hypothermic psychosis severe
hyperthyroidism and severe
thyrotoxicosis this thyrotoxicosis
already started during pregnancy
the mother was producing all the
hyperthyroid stimulating antibody and
this led to a very severe case of
neonatal fara toxicosis
with a shocked infant this child had to
be treated on the intensive care units
for a couple of days this child was born
with asphyxia tachycardia pulmonary
hypertension and cardiac insufficiency
and we have measured the Tartar of TSH
receptor stimulating antibody during
pregnancy in the mother blood as well as
in the neonatal in the child's blood
after delivery and all samples were
highly positive for stimulating antibody
giving us the whole story that this
mother who was hyperthyroid
was now switching from blocking antibody
to stimulatory antibody leading to
hyperthyroidism in the newborn we can
also observe another story this lady was
hyperthyroid who has been treated for
two years also for grave disease a very
intelligent lady she left our
institution unfortunately became
pregnant during pregnancy the same story
the physician the GP and the giant
ecologist did not look at the titer at
the presence of fair assimilating or
blocking antibody during pregnancy she
developed although she had grave disease
and was hyperthyroid she developed
blocking antibodies and these blocking
functional antibodies blocked the
development of the thyroid gland during
pregnancy inhibiting the development of
the fired gland these twins were born
with our thyroid gland at delivery with
severe cognitive impairment a very low
IQ and unfortunately these twins
now severe epilepsia so a clear case of
malpractice against emphasizing the
clinical relevance of measuring
stimulating and blocking antibodies
functional antibodies during pregnancy I
would go further and say if you're
planning pregnancy it's very important
to measure these antibody prior during
and after pregnancy just to be on the
safe side if the antibody titers are
high then you should go over also for
management of this lady during pregnancy
and look at her chart or children so
what are dealing with we are dealing
with a simple bioassay the principle is
that we are dealing with the cell with a
ferret cell bearing a chimeric TSH
receptor after binding of these
antibodies of the thyroid stimulating
antibody to the TSH receptor to its
ligand we have an increase of the second
messenger the cyclic AMP E and
stimulation of the crap pathways within
the nucleus and subsequent release of
the luciferase outside the cell and we
can clearly measure the lift lucifer
eyes release with analyzer reader this
is an incubation of the cells for 3
hours with the antibodies and leading to
increased transcription of the ELISA
phrase genes this is a very simple
methods and we are measuring in this
test the specimen to reference ratio the
specimen is the sample and the reference
standard is the bovine TSH this si has
been tested numerous time we have tested
this si within prospective trial
randomized trial this has been validated
also in our laboratory clearly showing
you the higher sensitivity and
specificity of this si
one of the first validation of this by
OSA has been published already eight to
nine years ago when looking at a large
number of untreated patients with Graves
hypothyroidism would it observe in a
majority of the cases very high serum
levels of TSI or thyroid stimulating
immunoglobulins while if you treat the
patients with auntie fire drugs these
starters are decreasing and you are
looking now the same panels in in blue
and it's you may observe that we can
significantly decrease the levels of
these stimulating antibodies in patients
who have been treated in contrast if we
look at controls the far right of the
stair Graham all serum levels of control
patients were negative patients with
thyroid nodules were also negative
patients with non thyroid or autoimmune
diseases were also negative for the SI
and patient with Hashimoto's thyroiditis
also so we had a very hard sensitivity
and very hard specificity of this test
if we go for a cut-off of 140 percent we
are reaching a very hard sensitivity of
99 percent area of the curve looking at
this ah sir our specimen reference to a
ratio of 140 percent this is the typical
ROC curve showing you actually the
excellent sensitivity and specificity of
this test I will go a further step and
say that if you are measuring the serum
tartar of these stimulatory antibody you
are predicting actually the course of
the disease and this has been shown when
looking at a very large number of
patients with autoimmune thyroid disease
more than thousand patients consecutive
and selected patients with autoimmune
thyroid disease where
at our institution and looking at the
first measurement of thyroid-stimulating
antibody we could predict the course of
grave disease the severity of Graves
hypothyroidism or and also the risk
and/or the risk of developing systemic
disease extra third on manifestation and
as you may see in the upper panel the
OHS ratio is 79% if you go for
quantitative T sub measurement if you go
for qualitative T sub measurement
meaning if the test is positive or no
the qualitative issue will even give you
an odds ratio of 26 so you may indeed
predict the course the severity the
chance of remission if you are measuring
at the first time the titer and the
concentration of these stimulatory
antibody at the first visit of the
patients we are able with this essay to
transfer or to convert the s are all
values in international units per litter
to better controls and compare the
results of this bioassay
with other conventional binding si since
all conventional bonnie essays are
expressing showing the results in
international unit per litter we can
convert the SRR percent results in
international units using a linear range
now the question is can we use the
measurement of these TSH receptor
antibody in the treatment of patients
with great disease in Europe all
patients with the grave disease are
being treated with aunty fire drug and
this medical therapy is effective in
nearly 60% of the cases it is becoming
more popular in the United States and
more and more endocrinologist thyroid
specialists are using amplifier drugs to
treat their patient
with grave stop authorities so our
question is can t SAP help predict the
following who will respond or relapsed
with our drug treatment how long should
we treat when to stop treatment and can
treatment be stopped if a patient is you
thyroid but T's are positive trying to
answer all these questions we did design
a prospective trials looking at patients
at the large group of patients with
untreated waves our pathologists
following them for years at least two
years giving them for 24 months
antithyroid drugs methimazole with a
dosage of 10 to 30 milligram per day as
starting those and C really controlling
and monitoring the titer of T said at
four weeks at eight weeks 1224 and so on
stopping the drug at 24 weeks and
following them for at least meanwhile
two years if you look at these patients
this is the classical dropout this is
the classical course of the
concentration of these antibody during
on to third drug treatment with
methimazole usually we observe a
normalization after six months of the t
cept arter but not all patients will
become negative we may observe sustained
t sep positivity for at least one year
or 18 months so it's very important to
continue and serially measure monitor
the antibody concentration at each visit
of the patients if we do this we do
observe also another important
phenomenon a very relevant and and
clinically relevant an important
phenomena which is the possible shift
from the stimulatory antibody shown here
in green and the appearance at week 36
of the blocking antibodies and the
appearance of the blocking on T
will impact the course of the disease
if the blocking antibodies are present
you will have a very high chance of
remission the patients are going into
you thyroidism you don't need any
tablets anymore this is the optimal time
to drop actually to stop antithyroid
drug treatment because the blocking
antibody are somehow neutralizing the
effect of the stimulating antibody so
this is very useful this is relevant and
this impacts the course of Graves
hyperthyroidism indeed we do observe in
patients with Graves hyperthyroidism at
the beginning TSI positivity or tea sap
the TBR are usually negative and if we
also measure the samples with a binding
si so-called trap si we do observe a
positive test a positive test for the
trap si meaning that we are dealing with
binding on T bodies in patients with
grave up authorities if we continue and
follow the patients and these patients
are developing blocking antibodies and
the TSI are disappearing this correlate
with a change of thyroid function at the
beginning they were hyper thyroid as
shown here in green after the appearance
of the blocking antibody they be become
hypothyroid so there is a shift from
hypothyroidism to hypothyroidism which
correlate with a shift from TSI to TBI
patients with TBI positivity become
hyper thyroid and if you are now relying
on the binding trap si you cannot
differentiate this there is no
differentiation why because the binding
si is always positive
if the TSI sample if the sample of
steers are positive the binding assay is
positive if the sample is blocking
antibody positive
the bonding s is also positive so the
bonding sa is just telling you that this
sample contents or the content of the
samples is antibody TSH receptor
antibody positive again showing you the
clear advantage of measuring both the SI
and TBI when monitoring the patient you
are on the safe side the diagnosis and
monitoring are more accurate and this
has a great advantage in contrast to
measuring the binding si now we were
interested in our laboratory to compare
our buyer si to different binding
conventional si this is one equipment in
my laboratory and this is my technician
doing this work every day and several
years ago we have cooperated with the
Mayo Clinic was Stephan Grable and we
have compared the sensitivity of the
buyer si with conventional binding si
this equipment I have shown you in a
previous slide and clearly as shown in
the blue arrow we are measuring antibody
against the TSH receptor at very very
low concentration with the biasing and
this is not the case with the binding si
you see that the concentration actually
of the antibody is much higher when you
are detecting these antibody with the
burning assay so a clear difference of
sensitivity between the bias a and the
bonding si and performing another trial
at our institution again comparing the
bioassay and the measurement of t-cell
with the bonding sa the trap si and
looking at parameters of analytical
performance limit of detection limit of
quantitation cutoff level half maximal
effective concentration ec50 these are
typical parameter of analytical
performance would observe a huge
difference of magnitude between the
buyer si and the binding si the trap
measurements clearly going from
differences of two hundred fifty four to
eight hundred twenty fold huge
difference between both essays and look
at hundred patients well characterized
hundred subjects and did evaluate the
sensitivity and specificity of seven
different essays five Barney essays and
two biases we had twenty healthy
controls we have sixty well
characterized untreated hyperthyroid
patients with Graves a plethora des they
were all TSH receptor antibody positive
and we had twenty well characterized
patients with Hashimoto thyroiditis
hypothyroid patients all these
hypothyroid patients were also TSH
receptor antibody positive so hundred
subjects well defined well characterized
all the healthy controls were devoid of
autoimmune disorders and the family
history was negative for autoimmune
disease and look at this we have been
looking at the bio si with two different
Eliza reader just to be on the safe side
all the samples the 60 samples of
patients with Graves hyperthyroidism
whereby OS a hundred percent bio si+
with both Eliza reader now if you go to
Barney assay these two were Eliza
so-called allies I say the Cronus essay
is widely distributed in the United
States and the Dynex is also in an
Isaiah say these three essays are
automated essay this one is from Siemens
the amyloid essay this one is from the
rush company and this one is from thermo
Fisher now have a look at the
sensitivity
of the automated of the three automated
Si and the two Eliza si only the Cronus
one using a monoclonal stimulatory
antibody is as sensitive in this test as
the biasing all other Barney assay
automated speedy automated essays are
less sensitive far less sensitive than
the biopsy if you look at the krypter
thermo Fisher koba's the Daleks so
clearly a difference of sensitivity now
we went a step further and diluted our
samples different steps one two three
want to know I'm one to twenty seven and
so on and compare these five essays the
bio essay with the Cronus Eliezer in
Malloy scripture dynamics and after one
dilution after one dilution 50 percent
of the binding si are losing their
sensitivity after second dilution even
more than 50 percent or now not
detecting any antibody and at higher
dilution only the buyer SA is still
detecting antibodies showing you the
greater sensitivity of the bioassay and
this is the most important message when
doing these experiments we have looked
at twenty patients to with Hashimoto
thyroiditis
all these patients were blocking
antibody positive explaining what these
patients were hypothyroid all these
patient with Hashimoto
were stimulatory antibody negative the
blocking antibody by OS a hundred
percent positive with both Eliza reader
and look at this very impressive very
impressive results
all five Bonnie si are highly positive
nearly hundred percent positive for
actually these 20 samples meaning that
these binding si these five essays are
not differentiating between blocking and
rating antibody they are just telling
you these twenty patients with Hashimoto
samples with Hashimoto thyroiditis are
actually positive in the binding si
although they have they are only
blocking antibody positive and not
stimulatory antibody to the antibody
negative so to sum up both stimulatory
and blocking antibody bioassay detect
TSH receptor antibody at very low
concentrations showing you the high
sensitivity of this buyer si the sample
dilution study showed higher detection
sensitivity for the stimulatory antibody
buyer si none of the binding si
differentiated between similar Tory and
blocking on t body the stimulatory and
blocking buyer say exclusively
differentiate between the TSH receptor
antibody functionality and demonstrates
higher performance than all automated
and Eliza burning assay so you would say
okay what is the clinical impact of this
buyer say well we have several positive
advantages over the binding assay
clearly we are dealing with actually a
better analytical sensitivity with a
buyer si the T sub and the TSI are
analytically more sensitive than all
Barney si we can measure antibodies in
patient of subclinical thyroid
dysfunction with lower TSH receptor
antibody concentration and this is not
the case with the binding assay because
the Bonnie si requires higher antibody
concentration in the serum to detect
these antibodies we can diagnose earlier
and treat earlier and manage the
patient's earlier the buyer si and the
measurement of stimulatory antibody
better predicts response to treatment
there is a pregnancy need-to-know
functional type of Auto antibody
this is important is the fetus at risk
for hyper or hypo
and T 70s I better correlate with
severity of extra final systemic disease
system a grave disease so do we have
primary clinical application yes of
course
the first one we can distinguish grave
disease from other causes of
thyrotoxicosis we do know that we read
your eyes at our isotope scanning is
none diagnostic and we do know that
radio star isotope is contraindicated
during pregnancy second we can predict
and monitor the response to drug therapy
in grave disease third we can predict
the risk of non-native grave disease
fourth we can confirm diagnosis of
graves our disease or systemic disease
so when should we use TSH receptor
antibody well to diagnose earlier to
differentiate better to predict systemic
disease especially with fair
assimilating antibody measurement to
monitor antithyroid drug treatment to
monitor fetal complication and pregnancy
to diagnose youth our third orbital
party to evaluate new drugs and
development all in all it is an improved
physician intervention
I thank you
dr. connealy thank you for that
informative presentation a quick
reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question and click a send button
dr. Haley will answer questions via
email only you may begin sending your
questions now
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today we would also like to
thank our sponsor quite ell for
underwriting today's educational webcast
webcast can be viewed on-demand laberd's
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thanks for joining us and we
hope to see you next time goodbye